We now introduce a new of
random variable, the
exponential random variable.
It has a probability density
function that is determined by
a single parameter lambda, which
is a positive number.
And the form of the PDF
is as shown here.
Note that the PDF is equal to
0 when x is negative, which
means that negative values
of X will not occur.
They have zero probability.
And so our random variable is a
non-negative random variable.
The shape of the PDF is as
shown in this diagram.
It's 0 for negative values, and
then for positive values,
it starts off, it starts off
at a value equal to lambda.
This is because if you plug
in x equal to 0 in this
expression, you get lambda times
e to the 0, which leaves
you just with lambda.
So it starts off with lambda,
and then it decays
at the rate of lambda.
Notice that when lambda is
small, the initial value of
the PDF is small.
But then the decay rate is also
small, so that the PDF
extends over a large
range of x's.
On the other hand, when lambda
is large, then the PDF starts
large, so there's a fair amount
of probability in the
vicinity of 0.
But then it decays pretty fast,
so there's much less
probability for larger
values of x.
Another observation to make
is that the shape of this
exponential PDF is quite similar
to the shape of the
geometric PDF that we have
seen before, the only
difference being that here we
have a discrete distribution,
but here we have a continuous
analog of that distribution.
Let's now carry out
a calculation.
Let us fix some positive number
a, and let us calculate
the probability that our random
variable takes a value
larger than or equal to a.
So what we're trying to do is
to calculate the probability
that the random variable
falls inside this
interval from a to infinity.
Whenever we have a PDF, we can
calculate the probability of
falling inside an interval by
integrating over that interval
the value of the PDF.
Therefore, we have to calculate
this particular integral.
And at this point, we can recall
a fact from calculus,
namely that the integral of the
function e to the ax is 1
over a times e to the ax.
We can use this fact by making
the correspondence between a
and minus lambda.
And using this correspondence,
we can now continue the
calculation of our integral.
We have a factor of lambda.
And then a factor of
1 over a, where a
stands for minus lambda.
So we get the minus
1 over lambda.
And then the same exponential
function, e to the
minus lambda x.
And because the range of
integration is from a to
infinity, we need to evaluate
the integral at a and infinity
and take the difference.
Now, this lambda cancels
that lambda.
We're left with a minus sign.
And from the upper limit, we
get e to the minus lambda
times infinity.
And then from the second term,
we have a minus sign that
cancels with that minus sign and
gives us a plus term, plus
e to the minus lambda a.
Now, e to the minus
infinity is 0.
And so we're left just
with the last term.
And the answer is e to
the minus lambda a.
So this gives us the tail
probability for an exponential
random variable.
It tells us that the probability
of falling higher
than a certain number falls off
exponentially with that
certain number.
An interesting additional
observation--
if we let a equal to 0 in this
calculation, we obtain the
integral of the PDF over the
entire range of x's.
And in that case, this
probability becomes e to the
minus lambda 0, which
is equal to 1.
So we have indeed verified that
the integral of this PDF
is equal to 1, as
it should be.
Now, let's move to the
calculation of the expected
value of this random variable.
We can use the definition.
Since the PDF is non-zero only
for positive values of x, we
only need to integrate
from 0 to infinity.
We integrate x times the PDF.
And this is an integral that
you may have encountered at
some point before.
It is evaluated by using
integration by parts.
And the final answer turns
out to be 1 over lambda.
Regarding the calculation of
the expected value of the
square of the random variable,
we need to write down a
similar integral, except
that now we
will have here x squared.
This is just another integration
by parts, only a
little more tedious.
And the answer turns out to
be 2 over lambda squared.
Finally, to calculate the
variance, we use the handy
formula that we have.
And the expected value of
X squared is this term.
The expected value of
X is this term.
When we square it, it becomes
similar to this term, but we
have here a 2.
There we have a 1.
And so we're left with just
1 over lambda squared.
And this is the variance of the
exponential random variable.
Notice that when lambda is
small, the PDF, as we
discussed before, falls off very
slowly, which means that
large x's are also
quite possible.
And so the average of this
random variable will be on the
higher side.
The PDF extends over a large
range, and that translates
into having a large mean.
And because when that happens,
the PDF actually spreads, the
variance also increases.
And this is reflected in this
formula for the variance.
The exponential random variable
is, in many ways,
similar to the geometric.
For example, the expression for
the mean, which is 1 over
lambda, can be contrasted with
the expression for the mean of
the geometric, which
is 1 over p.
And the relationship between
these two distributions, the
discrete and the continuous
analog, is a theme that we
will revisit several times.
At this point, let me just say
that the exponential random
variable is used to model
many important
and real world phenomena.
Generally, it models the time
that we have to wait until
something happens.
In the discrete case, the
geometric random variable
models the time until we see a
success for the first time.
In the continuous case, an
exponential can be used to
model the time until a customer
arrives, the time
until a light bulb burns out,
the time until a machine
breaks down, the time until you
receive an email, or maybe
the time until a meteorite
falls on your house.